all right
Mark Mark uh where'd you grow up where
you from originally Crystal Lake
Illinois Crystal Lake tell me about your
family growing up family was great uh
good upbringing mom and dad were awesome
got everything i' ever wanted you had
siblings uh I got two sisters and a
brother and you were you tell me about
your your what do you call it on your on
your face it's called ner fr brosa
it's a genetic disease that I got from
my father your dad had it yes but he had
just little bumps over his body I got
the worst case scenario of it and this
was something you were born like it it
showed up when when you were born yes it
showed up as capital A marks and if you
have more than seven that means you have
the genetic
disorder but but I think you you told me
you were born normal yes and then doctor
did surgery to remove a little lump on
the right eye which hit a nerve and it
made it
expand oh I see and it grew and got
larger grew yes how did that affect your
childhood growing up was hard I was
bullied most my childhood years until
about high school when the kids started
mature kind of got a little bit easier
for me but elementary junior high was
really rough I got called one i' Willie
I got caught one eye they made fun of me
from the movie
Goonies was that do to you young
man uh a lot of depression that resorted
to doing drugs to cope with the bullying
it made me feel better lot of self
harm do you have friends when you were a
kid uh a group of friends that weren't
the greatest friends they were in the
wrong
crowd uh
gangs in the drug drug you started at
what age uh about seventh grade started
smoking pot and drinking then as I got
into high school I should have doing
harsher
drugs how old are you now I am 42
[Music]
42 how far you go to school high school
you graduated yes what you've done
you've had jobs yes uh mostly factory
jobs uh it's so rough trying to find a
job with the way you look people still
discriminate against
and then with a criminal background it's
also harder to find a job what kind of
criminal uh drug use
domestics uh and then dealing
drugs is was it just as difficult as an
adult as it was as a kid for you yes and
no in what
ways uh like I said people have go fill
out a job for a job interview people
would look at
me they would second guess first the way
it looked and then with criminal
background that's what made it
harder what does this do to you
emotionally you you get depressed just
knowing that this is your fate you're
going to have to deal with this the rest
of your life
yes which is what leads to the drug use
correct have you had relationships yes I
uh After High School I had few few girl
girlfriends and I ended up marrying my
childhood girlfriend and had two kids
with her twins boy
girl and you're still married no I'm
separated would I mean would it must be
difficult for you to have hope for your
future I assume correct I'm a little
self-conscious going out to try to meet
somebody because the way I look but once
I get past that I think that I'm a good
person
inside yeah I'm sure this how how does
this impact
you inside I mean like who who Mark is
as a person how how does this affect you
as
a as a human being I just wish I look
like everybody else you can see the
you're handsome your your face is
handsome except for this deformity
deformity
yeah and you can't really remove it no
I've had about six surgeries and every
time excuse me they get do the surgery
it would go down but then it keeps
coming back so I I stopped like cuz I
don't like it put out and I just figure
what's the point if it's going to keep
coming
back and even if you try to get clean I
assume at some point what this does to
you emotionally makes you want to
relapse correct but I've done my
recovery program I'm currently in
recovery right now and I have too much
to lose if I go back to my drug use I
have my health I have my kids my family
do you have a good relationship with
your kids yes really good relationship
with my kids that's
great and have have they inherited this
no but they do accept their father
they're not
embarrass to go out with their
father they they they love their father
very much that's
great what is the hardest part of living
with
this just going out in
public people sharing it kind of gets
annoying but then you get used to it
what kind of reactions have you had the
ah daring
headlights like the pointing like
talking under your
breath it's going to make you you feel
very alone yes but then you know you get
used to it you get over
it having a romantic
relationship was was
that so the must be something you long
for we all long for that yeah I'm a lot
happier when I have that companionship
yeah and now that that's gone do
you you I mean you you hold on to hope
for another one perhaps one day yes or I
hope that I could reconcile with my
ex-wife after she gets overcome the
issues that she has right now she has
drug issues as well yes and I can't keep
clean unless she stay clean what what is
your drug crack cocaine
crack and using crack helped you just
num the feelings from all this yes n the
pain
yeah
is your family your parents are they
still around uh my dad deceased uh I
think in 2013 my mom's still around but
your parents were were good with you yes
I had an excellent upbringing yeah that
helps what advice would you give to
somebody who has something like this or
something that they're going through
that makes them makes their life
difficult just be who you are God gave
you life on this Earth so long as your
health is happy you know just be who you
are don't let other people think
differently of you are there people are
there women let's say
who can see past that and see who you
really are yes that's got to be a
wonderful feeling it is a great
feeling you've seen therapists about
this yes I'm also on depression
medication to help with the depression
problem and the PTSD that I have from
growing
up the dreams you had as a young man
with that that all that stuff gets
impacted by this I'm sure right yeah I
thought I would have been I thought if I
looked normal I could have went a lot
further in
life how do you look at it do do you see
there just you
just had some bad luck some genetic bad
luck
yeah
what's been the most difficult time of
your life childhood or now as an
adult childhood was the most difficult
part but as I got older to try to
succeed that's been difficult but I also
realized it was part of my drug
addiction yeah that complicates things
correct when you were a kid were were
there friends or people that were in
your class that saw through this and and
really yes I had a couple good best
friends growing up that's great yeah
they AC accepted me for who I
was yeah that's what we really all need
to do for each other isn't it exactly
all you need is those few good
friends you don't need a whole crowd you
know to be popular I'm sure living with
this gives you insights
into just living on living living
amongst other people and on this planet
what kind of things do you think you've
gained from from going through what
you're going
through worse self-confidence about
myself I can see that
and just I am who I am and you end up
valuing the things that are important
yes probably there's other kids that you
know are missing legs missing hands
worse than looking than me
kids that are stuck in wheelchairs can't
talk
yeah what would you say is your greatest
strength High
personality just being able
to help others I'm sure yes
yeah what's been the lowest lowest point
of your life what what's been the most
difficult time my drug addiction how how
how tough did your situation get
I was addicted to pain pills for 10
years and then I got clean on pain pills
then I got addicted to crack cocaine for
another 10 years so now is my longest
point in sobriety is born a have once
that I am today for all my
life since I started doing drugs at
a low
age what's your biggest regret yes a lot
of regret what would you say is your
biggest regret my biggest
regret not finishing school all the way
past High School getting into a
trade instead of I decided to just party
my way through the rest of my life After
High School were were there times where
you just
like it felt difficult to apply yourself
and and keep digging which life requires
yes cuz I rather you know go have my fun
do my
drugs and not be the man that I was
supposed to be forget about your pain
correct yeah I mean it must be a
wonderful feeling when somebody really
can see who you really are behind yeah
behind this right it's once they got to
know me and got to know my personality
and how I treated
them then they accepted me for who I was
the connection must be really really
something special right but it's also
hard to get that connection to get your
foot in the door and for them to you
know get to know you and get past the
way you look yeah you can't really go on
a dating app and expect anything no I
tried that and it it did not work no
repes
yeah I was in AAL
facilities all my life oh really due to
attempted
suicides when you were a young kid or
when you were an adult uh as I was an
adult because I just being
alone and then dealing
with you know not being
accepted caused me to hurt myself
self-destruct and then I got diagnosed
with bipolar
one which then they put me on medication
and they help me you know live life a
better
life not flip fing out all the time and
not knowing why you're flipping
out you you've been clean now for how
long four months four months and how how
is your
mood I feel great I haven't felt this
good in my life like I'm
attentive I smile more I laugh more
that's always a great indicator of oh it
is mental health cuz when I was doing
drugs all did it was not my pain and I
was you know not as active with my kids
not as active with the man that I wanted
to be I would go to work come home get
high you know play with my kids a little
bit and then the love of your kids must
be great cuz I love my kids they don't
see
what you know what's on your face they
just see what's inside your heart
exactly like my kids were never
neglected never around
anything but that's the greatest success
in my life life is my kids how old are
they 13 I have twins boy girl
mhm they mean everything to me but I
don't think if I didn't have my
kids I wouldn't be here my kids make me
want to live every
day and you're you're living where now
at a recovery home you're you're in a
sober living place
yes how long will you be there until I'm
ready to leave so I
I'm wanting to be there for at least six
to more months is is there is there a
situation or environment or job or
anything that would really help you with
your mental state yes once I start
working again just just being employeed
helps right oh yes because it keeps me
busy keeps my mind off of things keeps
you from getting in trouble exactly
versus sitting home at the recovery home
just going to your meetings coming home
sitting down waking up the next day
going to your meetings trying not to get
depressed correct
yeah because I go to AA meetings at
least five to six times a week that
helps me through my sobriety hearing all
the people's stories and what other
people has went through and they are
very accepting for who I am like it's
like a a big
family yeah having others to share your
stories with is a big help and people
benefit from my stories too
what I went
through when I got older I was working
in a convenience store and a doctor came
in and he asked me why I was working and
I told him well I need to make a living
and then he asked me why didn't you try
to go sue for the doctor's mistakes and
I told him that I didn't know I could
and then when I tried I was too late of
the statue limitations
law what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned from
having this
deformity it's a very unique situation
you got you know it's there aren't a
whole lot of people you can compare
yourself to and say well if they can do
it I can do it no you're not you're like
one of a kind y cuz it's all judgmental
and is your your right eye is functional
it works or is it no I got probably like
10% Vision because the being closed all
the time
yeah it's not painful it used to be
painful until the surgeries happened
they took the nerves out so the pain
would subside was the was the is it a
growth or what do you call it it's a
fibroma was was it larger at one point
yes it's a nine benign
tumor so they they reduced its size yes
it was dramatically bigger
really I was just tortured like
literally
tortured growing up like all all the
kids would just pick on you like it was
an everyday thing I'd go to school and
especially junior high it was
like every day I was getting picked on
there was not a day you went by through
sixth seventh and eighth grade that it
wasn't an everyday thing and it's and
I've never thought about hurting kids
I could get these kids that I get made
fun of and they go shoot the school up
and hurt other kids I just kids are
going to be kids I just didn't let it
bother me but then it did bother me
but I just coped with doing
drugs you
never retaliated or did anything violent
no I never even told like I'd come home
and tell my parents that was it never
told teachers cuz because they they
didn't do anything
anyways when you're by yourself
sometimes you just think like why me yes
why me and then out self harm a little
bit but yeah it was just why me why why
did I get stuck like
this do you believe in
God I'm starting to I didn't believe in
God for the longest time CU why would
you put me on earth like this
but then going through the recovery
program going to your higher power I'm
starting to believe in God and then I
have a really good childhood friend that
is getting me into believing in faith
and I'm starting to actually enjoy it
and that helps you yes now it's been
because I once I started going to church
with them and believing in God good
things have started to happen with for
me I got clean
I'm going to be
getting an apartment hopefully soon my
kids my family back
together so yeah once God came in the
picture it started to get a little bit
better you certainly deserve a good a
nice break here and there don't you yeah
but I did it to
myself because of the drug
use because of the drug use yeah yeah
I I think that if I wasn't so far into
the drug use I could have went
farther but the drugs held me
back was there anyone in your life that
was really very helpful and supportive
and like your parents or anybody like
that my mom and my dad
especially and then I had a two good
friends that were very supportive of me
like they would defend me and and S up
for
me when I was getting bullied that's
great
yes but then when I got older in my 20s
when I went to the bars and stuff
everybody loved me like everybody
accepted me really yeah that's great
like there was one certain bar that I
just would attend to all the time and
they all knew me when I walked in and
once they get to know you and know know
what you're all
about it becomes much easier to exactly
like it it's just getting to know
me like I'm a very good guy I treat you
good I respect people as long as you
respect me I'm going to give you that
same respect
back yeah that's really what it's all
about isn't it it's all about respect I
think you got to give respect to earn
the
respect all right Mark thank you so much
for sharing your story thank you I wish
you lots of luck from whatever you do
from here on thank you thanks